good morning Hank it's Monday August 3rd
it's Esther day you'll never guess where
I found myself Hank I'm in agloe New
York so Hank aglow is here or possibly
here or possibly here it's hard to be
certain when you're talking about a
place that is only sometimes real so
anyway here's some footage from what I
think is a glow for Esther day on Esther
day we remember our friend Esther Earl
as she wanted us to by celebrating love
in all its many splendors not just
romantic love but the love within
families and friendships today is the
day we say I love you to those people
even when it's hard in fact especially
when it's hard it's also the one day a
year that Hank and I acknowledge our
love for each other verbally so ok in
accordance with Esther's wishes Hank I
reluctantly acknowledge that I love you
immensely I think what I've gone through
challenging times because of the bad
wiring in my brain or physical illness
or whatever it gets very hard for me to
escape the prison of my own brain like
the pain / fear / obsessiveness becomes
so consuming that i struggled to
empathize or listen well and this can
become a vicious cycle like you're in so
much pain that you become so
self-involved that it becomes difficult
to connect to anyone which in turn
increases the pain and the self
involvement and etc I can't tell you how
many times your patience and empathy
have shut down that spiral for me it's
something you've done for me
consistently since you were like three
so yeah thank you and I just admire you
a lot and I think you're awesome and I
love you if you don't know about Esther
check out her book you can also go to
dftba calm or t SW G org to support the
charity this star won't go out which was
created by Esther his family and
provides direct support to families of
children with cancer links in the doobly
Doo also I'm gonna do a question Tuesday
tomorrow nerdfighters so please leave me
questions ideally brief ones in comments
thank you
dftba Hank you'll see me tomorrow